non-minimalists
how do you let go of limiting beliefs
i'm an aspiring artist and as josh may
know
that means i've been drawing pretty
infrequently lately
i have this belief i must make a profit
from my art and it's
stopped me dead in my tracks but worst
of all it's kept me from feeling happy
in my everyday life
how do you minimize your inner critic
now ben i think this is fascinating
because we often
conflate sort of creativity with needing
to make a profit right away but
sometimes that actually spoils it
it it does look the
the most satisfied and fulfilled that
you will feel in life
is if you're living out your life's true
purpose right we're all born with a
unique skill set
and i think that everyone should have
some kind of single succinct purpose
statement the thing that gets you out of
bed in the morning you know what the
japanese would call ikigai or in italy
would be called the plan davida
but this idea that you know why it is
that you are here and what your unique
purpose is you know both of my children
have purpose statements one is to
create art that elicits powerful
emotions from people
right that's that's his purpose
statement um
mine is to uh to read write
learn teach sing speak compete and
create
in full presence and selfless love to
the glory of god
and that's my purpose that's what rips
me out of bed
in the morning one very important
component
of your purpose statement is once you
have found it once you have formed it
and you do this by thinking about the
things that you really enjoyed to do
when you were a kid
the things that make time go by very
quickly for you now put you in the
so-called
zone the unique skills that you have
that allow things to come easy to you
and in when you've identified all of
those things you can piece together
a purpose statement based on what it is
that you're actually naturally good at
and feel a great deal of joy from when
you're engaged in that
but if you hone your purpose statement
down you have the perfect purpose
statement and then you go forth into the
world and your goal with that purpose
statement is maslow's hierarchy
right i'm going to use this purpose
statement to get my house to feed myself
and my family to make a lot of money to
get a better car
have a bigger home etc that
that's pretty unfulfilling versus this
idea
that you think i have my purpose
statement i'm going to go out and
love as many other people as possible
with that purpose statement
right and i've even couched that into my
own statement you don't have to do that
but you know
in full presence and selfless love for
others is is kind of tailed at the end
of my purpose statement because i want
that constant reminder
but you find your purpose statement and
then you go out into the world
and you love other people with that
purpose statement so uh so
uh amber is the is the gal called in
yeah she if she creates art
and she has an avatar she has that
person in mind who's going to be seeing
her art
and being moved being emoted having some
kind of a connection to her art some
kind of inspiration you know what
what is the end goal of what her art is
going to do
for people i guarantee that if you are
creating your business around a service
for other people
and loving other people the money will
come if you come out from the other
angle i
i want to do this to make money you'll
often get disconnected from your true
self you'll hold yourself back from
creating what you actually want to
create
because you will experience what one of
the more common regrets of the dying is
living your life creating or doing what
the world expects you or what you think
the world expects you to do versus
staying true to your authentic self
stay true to your authentic self love
other people with your purpose
and the money will come yeah there's
this thought of you know
ryan and i will sometimes say that good
businesses make money great businesses
make a difference
and right now amber is striving
through this thought process because
she's been acculturated to believe that
i have to make money first it's the
primary driver of doing what i'm going
to do
well you're striving for at best a good
business
but a great business as you said it
helps helps other people solve
their problems now it can you can do
that through art you can do that through
writing you can do it through plumbing
right there are different ways to solve
people's problems i loved
your purpose statement because there was
nothing that even hinted toward
earning more revenue or maximizing cash
flow or anything
like that one billion customers in ten
years like i i don't think those are
those are bad objectives
to be on a business blueprint for
example or even
as part of the the core purpose of a
business
you know having having some kind of
metrics that you want to reach i think
that's smart
but in terms of the value that you want
to deliver it it really should be
for other people the the other thing
that's important for a creator
for an artist like amber is to realize
that it's okay to outsource a lot of the
business
and the financial decisions and the
delivery
and the publishing and the shipping to a
team
thus equipping and enabling you and
freeing you to create
i've personally found that as i add team
members to my team and i'm able to
just focus on the writing and not think
okay who's processing the credit card if
someone wants to go
buy a book from this article i wrote and
you know who's
monitoring whatever instagram
advertisements for this
product that i have in my mind that i
want to create if i free myself from
that by surrounding me with other people
who do a lot of the business and the
financial stuff it allows me to go into
creator mode and not
have those little thoughts ticking away
at the back of my mind as i'm trying to
create i'm trying to write because amber
is trying to make art
and so that's a big part of it too is
you want to outsource some of this stuff
to a team
who can do some of that thinking for you
and in an era
of virtual assistants and you know
mechanical
turks i think they're called nowadays
it's a
it's a term used to describe you know
people who do things for you on the
internet
it's pretty easy scalable and cost
effective to find
people who can do things like your
landing page your
credit card pro you know all of that is
pretty achievable in this day and age
i like i like the advice to yeah focus
on creating it
it sounds to me like you're saying focus
on creating more and maybe
on the results less even though i mean
we should care about the results
but if you're just focusing on the
results that's gonna stunt your creation
what i like about your uh your purpose
ben is
it's it's very lasered but it's also in
a way very broad
because you can in many ways uh fulfill
that purpose it doesn't mean that you
have to be
a an author who gives great advice on
health
there are many things that you can do to
fulfill that purpose so that would be
something i would recommend is when
someone is coming up with this this
purpose statement
it doesn't have to be like oh i have to
be an artist and make money
uh keep it as broad as possible the the
statement could be
i want to create work that is going to
inspire others or move people
emotionally
and uh yeah i think that'll help take a
little bit of the pressure off
from from amber here ryan the there's
the thing about when we're talking about
clutter here because
what i hear in her question even and ben
you tell me what you think about this
but
really what you're talking about is
taking some of these obligations that
she doesn't look forward to you're just
talking about taking those off the table
and and maybe at first you don't have
the ability to do that you know everyone
who starts off as an entrepreneur or a
solopreneur
you might have to do everything on your
own for a while just like ryan and i did
when we started the minimalists a decade
ago it was literally just the two of us
remember going to bookstores and like
measuring
the margins oh yeah yeah we literally
did everything
um we were driving around his toyota
corolla from bookstore to bookstore
and we would do events you know selling
our book and and so like
sometimes but eventually you'll get to a
point where in order to add value to
people's lives you have to take some of
that clutter away
you do and and i do not want to paint
this all
as you know roses and sunshine and
unicorn farts like like there's some
hard work that has to be done i
experienced the same thing when i was a
personal trainer
you know working 10 to 12 hour days with
clients in a gym
you know counting reps and running
people up the stairs and
you know and demonstrating push-ups and
squats i would get
home typically around 9 or 10 p.m i
would have a quick dinner with my wife
and then i would be up until about 2 a.m
programming my website creating php
scripts creating the the credit card
processing forms
doing the adobe indesign work on my
self-published books and i was sleeping
about four to five hours a night for a
good
three years to lay the foundation there
are probably things that i was doing
then that even then i could have
outsourced
but there there is there there is a time
when you are gonna find yourself
working a little bit more than you would
like to in order to lay the foundation
for you to then say you know have enough
money set aside to bring on your first
virtual assistant or to outsource your
first project but
you know again 99 design square space
and all these websites that make it
pretty achievable to do it at a low cost
dictates that
you know you're not going to have to
moonlight for the next decade but
yeah there may be a few months or even a
couple of years where you at you know
life gets gets tough and and i can tell
you that most successful people
have had to put in the hard work and you
know for me in the fitness industry
that's one of the most
annoying things when you see some kid
pop up on instagram with a nice body
and this you know crappy little pdf that
they made for the workouts that
that they did you know they're they're
on hormones or andro or steroids or
whatnot and
they've got everything photoshopped they
they have almost zero certifications or
degrees or
you know an online moonlit you know
personal training certification
and you know all of a sudden they've got
300 000 followers and
they're filthy stinking rich even though
they never really put in that much of
the hard work there's some of those
people out there
um but i think ultimately in the long
run
um society kind of filters out
who actually knows their stuff and who
gets results versus who's just a pretty
face who's a flash in the pan
yeah by the way if you are completely
careless like that and you sell someone
a pdf for twenty dollars they're not
gonna come back to you not gonna
you you've lost all the trust with them
and so part of that purpose statement
can actually
have something to do with establishing
establishing trust
with people so that you you're adding so
much value to their lives that they're
eager to pay you in some ways and we do
that with our patreon
um you know a large portion of our
audience listens to the podcast for free
but then
there are you know five or six thousand
people who listen on patreon
and they give us the opportunity to pay
sean pay jordan pay yes
value value so when i write an article
you'll often find at the end of my
articles on my website
there are opportunities to purchase
things like i hope you enjoyed this
article if you want more you know
grab my book because there's there's you
know 18 other tips
on this same topic of say fat loss in my
book or
you know now that i've taught you all
about you know curcumin or
turmeric here's the opportunity to
actually grab a product that i created
that will help your your
joints or something like that however
whenever i'm writing an article or
creating a piece like that my goal
is for someone to walk away from having
read that a better person a more
educated person
i want their lives to be better whether
or not they purchase
anything at all same with my podcast all
i want to do is help people
if there are things in there you know go
to the show notes and grab this from
amazon and it supports the podcast or
you know buy this supplement or grab
this book
fine but the goal is to deliver value
and to educate that's always at the top
of the totem pole
and if people want to buy stuff based on
that great but the number one priority
is to create value and if you get that
backwards you're
not just screwing other people you're
screwing yourself
because if you're not if you're not
serving
those people then well if they don't
feel served they don't feel compelled
to you know to stick around oh yeah we
see this in in even
you know internet marketing you know
long video sales letters
or um or pitches for products etc
the best ones have a great deal of
education built in
if you read them they'll always start by
explaining explaining explaining and
there's this molecule on that molecule
or
you know this technique or that
technique or this approach or that
approach
and then at the very end or towards the
end that's when they say and here's a
solution that ties together all these
things you know and there's
there's even you know people who sell
products online with a with an exact
script an exact sequence you know first
you lay down the value here
and then you explain some of the
components of your product then you have
the testimonials etc
but all the best ones start with educate
the customer give them
mad value yeah what do you think about
uh
suggesting amber kind of shift her
reward so right now
her reward is making money so instead of
having that as the goal yeah it should
be to yeah move people with their art or
uh maybe yeah i don't know just
something that isn't so
driven uh by this specific result
because i feel like when we do that
you go from like getting to do something
to having to do something
because right now if we can weigh the
magic wand and like give her okay we'll
pay you you know
a dollar for every single piece of art
you put out i mean that's just going to
make her
do something over and over again because
she's expecting that dollar
but instead of getting the yeah they get
to do it
now i have to do it to get this dollar
for each piece and the result of that
can be
pretty much the complete opposite of
what ryan holiday dictates in his
book the perennial best seller you wind
up creating you know let's say for me as
an author i could pump out
five to seven dollar pdfs and cheap
kindle books on amazon
all day long and i could profit heavily
from that
and at the end of the day you know
thinking forward as
as as dark as it may seem to my deathbed
i don't see myself being incredibly
fulfilled you know with
seven six-pack abs you know 50-page
downloadable pdfs
on amazon or something like that i want
to write something
that is that that's big that's epic
that's going to stick that people
come back and return to over and over
again and
again if you're caught up in the
money-making part of things
you can as you've just alluded to ryan
you can you can create these whatever
one dollar pieces of art and sell them
all day long and make a profit
but i think that creating true art
creating
masterpieces is far more fulfilling
at the end of the day and so that's
another thing to bear in mind
is that with profit as the primary
incentive
you'll often create slightly more
shallow less meaningful products just
you can get them out there
ship and pay the bills yeah well the
opposite of a shallow product for sure
is this uh boundless book amber i'm
gonna send you a copy actually i'll send
you this copy
maybe we'll even get ben to sign it for
you i'll de-value it so you cannot ebay
it
and uh and there you go let me ask you
um
how how how big was this book before the
editing started was it like
twice as twice as much like did you have
to cut a lot together manuscript that i
turned into the publisher was 1200 pages
those those three years of working with
a couple of research assistants a
scientific editor
the the publishing company's editorial
team and
so we cut about 600 pages because the
the current
version is 650 pages however i didn't
want to kiss my babies goodbye
so i put all the extra content that got
cut from the book
onto kind of a hidden resources section
of
the website for the book and so when
people get the book they can go and put
in their little amazon order number or
their order number
and get access to all the hidden content
but that
that was tough because the way i write
books is i generally have a shared cloud
drive in google
and then a separate folder for each
chapter of the book with all the
research all the references the
podcasts the audiobooks the people i
want to interview the ideas i have
there's a separate folder in
that main google drive for each separate
chapter of the book
and so it winds up turning into a little
bit of a beast over time but at the same
time
as you revise you have the previous
revision this paragraph got cut but
we've got
you know the very first version of the
chapter that was written and so
for me kissing my babies goodbye
wasn't as painful because i knew they'd
they'd live on that you know they're not
in the actual published manuscript but
they're still
online so that kind of freed me up a
little bit to have a little less pain
about the editing process